liebe freunde wir schauen uns heute 100
fakten über spongebob schwammkopf nicht
ob ich dass wir 100 stück schaffen
werden aber man guckt stellen euch der
liberation seine freunde 100 fakten
es ist so crazy diese spongebob stimme
im anschluss bester freund patrick war
ehemals das aggressiver barbesitzer
geplant was
machte eigentlich jetzt jetzt einfach
irgendwie da patrick irgendwie keinen
job mehr wild und der folge
unaussprechlich haben die englischen
original sprecher wirklich geflucht und
dies im nachhinein durch den lauten
zensiert
ich dachte einfach mit dem satz
aufgehört und haben dann das tor gemacht
habe anscheinend wirklich irgendwelche
körpers wörter gesagt spongebob
schwammkopf wurde am 14 juli
1986 geboren und er ist somit 34 jahre
alt was
nach gigs bottrop einfach 34 ortszeit
beim kinderkriegen spongebob sollte
ursprünglich von speyer heißen doch da
der name durch eine reinigungsfirma fünf
wischmopp geschützt war wurde aus bonn
spongebob papa macht auch viel mehr sinn
spongebob hört sich viel besser an als
poncho
respons boy verleiht dem ganzen noch
mehr englisch amerikanischen charakter
die man aber eh ständig sponge art und
bob ist ja irgendwie besser dümmer also
für spongebob geeignet dort einen
kommentar auf der dvd zur ersten staffel
basieren einige hauptfiguren auf den
sieben todsünden dazu habe ich schon
einmal ein video auch leider stimmt das
auch schon mal gehört
das plankton wollen
lust ist die krosse krabbe stellt nicht
wie viele es denken eine schatzkiste ist
sondern eine hummer falle da ja
das habe ich auch schon aufgehört den
fakt weil so werden oder wurden früher
humer gefangen
und darm ist der krebs ein hummer ist
das relative spongebob und planktons
frau karin sind in wirklichkeit
verheiratet also nicht in der serie aber
dafür spongebob sprecher tom kelly und
carens sprecherin jill telli im echten
leben
das finde ich immer so lacht wenn
irgendwelche
schauspieler die in echt irgendwie
zusammen spielen auch zusammen sind so
wie tom holert und seien daher keine ob
die noch zusammen sind aber die waren
doch glaube ich mal mit der episode
königlicher quatsch erfährt man dank dem
stammbaum der stars dass patrick und
gary cousins sind
[Musik]
und gary sick of the work stephen
hillenburg ist der erfinder von
spongebob schwammkopf und war
meeresbiologe
das ist aber überhaupt nicht in die
serie eingeflossen
die machen teilweise
unter wasser
gibt ein wenig sinn berühmter stars
laien oftmals figuren ihre stimme so
sprach beispielsweise johnny depp den
schamanen jack bauer laguna in der folge
die welle zurück oder auch scarlett
johansson welche prinzessin mit dem
ersten film ihre stimme lieh was
also die fakten sind schon zeigen dass
spongebob also diese kompletter film
oder die serie auch deutlich komplexer
ist als man im ersten moment vermuten
mag und von frank rost ist teil der lgbt
community wie nicht
bestätigt
na ja der grund warum patrick so dumm
ist ist sehr weise sterne kein gehirn
besitzen
also
hätte man ja auch sagen kann ja patrick
wird gespielt von einer koralle die
haben ja auch keinen gehirn obwohl
patrick so dumm ist ist da die einzige
bekannte figur die einen
college-abschluss hat
[Musik]
patrick start einen college-abschluss
dann war das der total frech dass andere
sich jetzt der verkleidet hat
nürnberg wollte unbedingt verhindern
dass die leute spongebob für ein stück
käse halten deswegen wollte er unbedingt
in seinen namen das wort sponge einbauen
ja aber macht ja auch sinn
immer in der krise schon toll mit den
löchern und blabla aber dadurch dass er
sicher aufsaugt hätte man es eigentlich
auch schon dadurch interpretieren könnte
man das anderen bereichen open brauchen
einfach nike zeichen es existiert eine
pilzart namen geforce klare punch die
welche nach spongebob schwammkopf
benannt wurde da der pilz optisch einen
schwamm gleicht
hsh wieder typisch amerikaner
guck mal der schwander die courage sieht
aus wie spongebob denn nehmen wir jetzt
einfach spongebob chorale so richtig
kommerziell das bikini atoll ist eine
insel welche in den vierzigern und
fünfzigern zum testen von nuklear bomben
verwendet wurde bei diesem atoll handelt
es sich um eine kleine insel die in der
serie des öfteren zb beim wechsel von
tageszeiten gezeigt wird warte mal
diese insel sieht man ja auch beim start
vom intro die gibt es wirklich das ist
crazy die serie spongebob schwammkopf
läuft in 170 verschiedenen ländern mit
48 verschiedenen sprachen trank
über hat es geschafft die verhindert was
der allein mit der serie verliehen hat
ist der crazy oder noch das ganze
drumherum die ganz markus ganze
franchise das ganze merchandise ist echt
brutal viel sollen der falke spongebob
in zufalls land wurde die berühmte
creepy pasta skateboards zurzeit
parodiert
25 trotzdem squid interviews englischen
namen squibb wort handelt es sich bei
ihm nicht um einen tintenfisch sondern
um einen oktopus
ich habe mal der referent ist
ja auch skateboard
machen ob du wirst mir sogar otto
otto wort heißen
warte was das verstehe ich überhaupt
nicht hielt ihn die bottoms
nachbarstädte in new york city und bass
vegas sind wie man es wahrscheinlich an
den namen erkennen kann parodien der us
amerikanischen städte new york city und
las vegas ist immer verrückt finde ich
auch bei gta wo die nicht los angeles
gebaut haben sondern los santos mit aber
allen sachen aus los angeles oder auch
gta 4 wo sie es nicht new york sondern
liberty city genannt haben
wahrscheinlich wegen liberty city und
new york city
dürfen die das nicht aufgrund der rechte
oder woran liegt das echte name des
nachrichtensprecher fischer toni l
dieser tisch der so hoch ansetzen die
ganze zeit so macht heißt doch nicht
allein
patrick sandys kuppel die große gabe und
der abfalleimer stehen auf der schnecken
straße
straße auch heißmann sport es hat einige
tolle mal auf fünf fakten und dann am
ende weil 100 fakten wollen jetzt auch
nicht geben spongebob bin ich ganz
ehrlich in winterbach die ananas als
spongebobs haus da er dachte dass
spongebob den geruch einer ananas mögen
könnte
das puzzle bisschen schwamm wie soll es
denn mögen und des schwammes erschaffen
von euch also ihr könnt sagen was er
machen was eigentlich immer ragen der
serie american dad gibt es mehrere
spongebob referenzen unter anderem gibt
es eine bananen version von spongebob
als
35 in einer minute und voller hass ist
eine referenz spongebobs ananas jimmy
max und karl unter wasser tauchten das
finde ich immer verrückt wenn in anderen
filmen oder serien wiederum andere filme
und serien aufgegriffen wurden und was
ich mich auch immer schon gefragt waren
die das vorher abgesprochen oder ist es
wirklich darauf flach gemacht so gucken
wer es merkt ein kleines easter egg
einmal vielleicht freuen die sich vom
sender nebenan und so das finde ich echt
mal ein bisschen bisschen interessanter
name dem original wolfen junior und
gerald wie schlecker recht in der
deutschen nachdem er als schnecke ich
alles klar letzter zwei fakten in der
episode das ausbildungs video erfährt
man dass die krosse krabbe früher ein
altersheim war
aber
dann gibt's führung keinen sinn mehr
dass mister crepes die krabbe in dieser
hummer falle drin sein geschäft hat
weil dann noch schlechter frei ist auch
ein bisschen zu doll letzter facti
krosse krabbe im englischen krusty
crêpes genannt wurde vom cross die
bürger aus den simpsons inspiriert
ich dachte vor dem hunger käfig aber
okay vielleicht der name ich hoffe ihr
habt was gelernt über spongebob meine
damen und herren in dem dichten infos
ihr dann völlig auf dem pausenhof an
geben könnte oder wenn ihr das nicht nur
spongebob guckt oder keine ahnung was
dann seid ihr dieser bierfreund
irgendwie so sachen weil es niemand
weist aber egal wenn es euch gefallen
hat dann das geld einen daumen hoch
unter dem video er dort aber nicht
meinen kanal und klickt auf die glocke
um weitere videos nichts zu verpassen
ich bin ganz ehrlich hab jetzt richtig
bock sportschuhe zu gucken also mache
ich das jetzt